bienvenidos a 5 minutos con él nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia foto gracias por estar con
nosotros y cuéntenos aunque ya 115
países comenzaron la vacunación se han
aplicado también unas 265 millones de
dosis la o&m se ha dicho que el exceso
de confianza en las vacunas puede tener
una nueva ola de ccoo y 19 cuéntenos la
forma en la que se comportan los seres
humanos tiene también sin duda un
resultado sobre el avance de la pandemia
cómo hacer para que no exista un
relajamiento de las medidas de
prevención individual y comunitaria y
que hay que dejarle también no hay que
dejarle todo eso a las vacunas usted qué
opina
desde luego la vacunación sin la
desaceleración de los casos no va a ser
exitosa y por eso es que mantener la
disciplina hasta que la inmunidad hasta
que el número de personas sea que se ha
vacunado sea suficiente para poder
cortar la cadena de transmisión aún no
estamos ni siquiera en el 2 o 3 por
ciento de la humanidad vacunada estamos
todas muy lejos de la inmunidad que
necesitamos para poder retirar las
medidas de confinamiento por ahora la
indiana no está precisamente esta semana
los gobernadores de los estados de texas
y mississippi en estados unidos a los
cuales de sus manos más anunciaron que
no será obligatorio el uso de
mascarillas y que los negocios podrán
operar al 100% de su capacidad en este
exceso de confianza en el avance de la
vacunación
completamente y es que hay una lógica
que la lógica pandémica la lógica del
virus no es el virus se comporta de
acuerdo a su naturaleza pero nosotros
podemos modificar para que aumente el
número de casos o para que disminuya
haciendo estas medidas simplemente vamos
a pasar que en un par de meses tenemos
que volver a contar el número de
fallecidos el número de camas en cuidado
intensivo y volver a las restricciones
esto que hicieron es demasiado
apresurado y todavía no era el momento
para hacer bueno pues veamos también lo
que está pasando en brasil y usted qué
opina del hecho de que no paran los
récord diarios de muertes y los
contagios y siguen también al alza como
pudimos ver por ejemplo el estado de sao
paulo dónde se ha decretado un nuevo
confinamiento
es que la política de vacunación tiene
que ser armónica entre estado sociedad
líderes sociales y todos los actores
este no es el momento para desunir este
el momento para hundirme lo que hemos
visto en brasil es una disociación entre
la política del estado y la ciudadanía
los líderes científicos y el desorden ha
llevado a que un país que puede tener
vacunas que tiene recursos económicos
esté rezagado en la vacunación y con el
número de casos más altos en el mundo y
registrando incluso más fallecidos que
eeuu es lamentable lo que pasa en brasil
y ojalá que la armonía que se retome es
para que puedan tener su vacunación
exitosa doctor se viene la semana santa
para los católicos podría llegar una
nueva ola de kobe si no se mantienen las
medidas de prevención
yo creo que debemos comportarnos como la
semana santa del año pasado en donde se
la virtualidad y otras formas de
celebraciones y las celebraciones al
aire libre editar procesiones y
aglomeraciones es parte de lo que
debemos hacer para poder conectarnos
como sociedad a una normalidad en un par
de años más pero tenemos que hacer esto
no es un sacrificio
esta es la adaptación natural que
tenemos que tener a la situación que
estamos viviendo actualmente ojalá se
mantengan las mismas medidas que el año
anterior doctor y por otro lado una
persona que ya ha tenido kobe podría
recibir una sola dosis de la vacuna o
requiere las dos de acuerdo a los
estudios que se han presentado en varios
países europeos es probable que con una
dosis sea suficiente pero las
recomendaciones actuales es completar el
esquema después de 90 días de haber
superado el código de recientemente
después de 90 días y probablemente
después de 180 días sea necesario la
inmunidad con dos vacunas es probable
que las personas de una sola dosis son
aquellas personas que tres a seis meses
se han recuperado
y eso es como una medida razonable en
estos momentos también para poder
aumentar el número de bakú lado bueno y
rápidamente doctora alguna medida en
particular para prevenir lo que está que
ver con las nuevas variantes que han
aparecido recientemente
la lógica de la pandemia es que el virus
se sigue expandiendo y en la medida que
haya mayor replicación mayor tasa de
mutación es eso llegar a linajes algunos
que pueden empeorar la pandemia porque
pueden ser más agresivos y infectar más
a personas por eso es muy importante que
mantengamos la exageración de los casos
hasta que logremos que el 70 por ciento
de nosotros tengamos inmunidad es un
llamado a la a mantener nuestras medidas
de restricción lo mayor posible gracias
doctor pérez por estar en plan 24 y
ustedes gracias continúen con más cifras
24 punto com
[Música]